hall of famer two-time world series
champ and 14-time all-star
want a couple mvps johnny bench joining
us on the program johnny thanks for
joining us how are you today
hi i'm wonderful dan nice to be with you
well
help me out with the unwritten rules
here i know you're old school here but
fernando tatis jr
on a 3-0 pitch up 10 in the eighth
inning
was a 10-3 i should say but up 10 runs
uh is supposed to what in that situation
well hit it as far as it can i mean
it's three and oh okay throws it you
take a pitch it's three and one now the
pitcher makes a great pitch it's three
and two
the next pitch you ground into a double
play and
everybody goes home happy oh okay
so it's like the unwritten rule if you
you know when you got a no hitter you
don't but
to get a base hit to break up the no
hitter no nobody wants to get
nobody wants to do that but i can
understand i mean they think they're
getting whipped and everything else but
it's the eighth inning i mean uh texas
has a as a great offense
and and while we've been watching in the
light you know with oakland lately
there's going three or four runs in the
ninth inning and winning ball games that
they've been trailing in
and no you know i think this this
started in the early part of spring
training what people said you know
with because we're only playing a
limited schedule of games
it's important to win every game and i'm
telling you a grand slam
on your resume is a pretty good little
thing to have and
now i did not i just now heard you say
that he had
the manager of giving him a take yeah uh
3-0 i'm not really looking down to the
third base
yeah what should i do here well i mean
he got
he got the bases loaded somehow somehow
they didn't have a lot of you know
things going on he's 3-0 with tattoos
because he's got to be really careful
with his young man
he's already hit a home run in the game
and uh
now it's like well you better make a
pretty good pitch you know
it's like oh okay it's three and i'll
just groove it and and
it'll happen but you know i don't i
don't have a problem with it
i think it's what with a limited limited
season i think no matter what you've got
to take advantage of every situation
when
every possible game you have and you
know the padres are having a great
season off to a great start
and texas has been playing well enough
uh i just think
you know if you respect the other team
in two ways first of all you give them
the respect though you don't swing at it
okay fine but okay it's 10-3 you're up
by seven
you know a couple of little bing bang
and a couple of bloops and a blast and
all of a sudden
you're that you're you know it's 10
seven or ten eight going into the
ninth inning now all of a sudden said
man i wish i had an edict tape
no i just i think it's fine i mean i
don't have a problem with it and
and i'm sure that they understand that a
little frustration that they got into
that situation they got battered around
pretty good they've already given up a
three-run home or twoing
and now it's 10-3 and here they are
ready to do it so he hits a double or
hits into a double in double play
you know the whole scenario changes but
well you played the game
i mean would you been up there attacking
yes
if i'm a professional johnny then i'm up
there swinging
i understand if you know if this is
little league or
you know something uh legion ball maybe
but
you know your job is to get me out and
my job is not to get myself out so
you'll feel better about yourself
i mean imagine if you're facing sandy
koufax
and you're going sandy you're throwing
it too hard we can't hit you could you
could you let it bob gibson imagine you
say to bob gibson hey bob
stop throwing it so hard yeah
yeah and please no more wrinkles no more
wrinkles don't try
don't start little things that spin and
break down because i'm not real good on
the curveball and i can't hit the
sliders
mind it's mind if you just sort of
groove a couple right here and
everything else of course they could
groove it you wouldn't hit it anyway so
that was the situation and you know it's
uh
is this all we got to talk about today i
mean is this the
most important subject in the world some
guy hits a grand slam because you went
3-0 on him
and you couldn't find the plate on the
three first three pitches but you can
group one down the middle
yeah you know you just got the wrong guy
and also the other topic
is what's going on with the cardinals
that they put everybody else in a bad
situation here johnny that
now you have to play all these games but
now you're forcing
all these other teams who did it right
and
you're not going to have everybody have
the same number of games i think at the
end of the regular season so if you're
the commissioner
how are you deciding you know what
you're going to base the playoffs on
percentages yeah but is that fair
if i'm if you play 48 games but i play
60 and i might get in because i have a
better percentage in 48 and you
played all of your games there well i
mean that
that unfortunately as they even talked
about this at the beginning of all of
this when they
were trying to figure it out and then of
course you know the phillies went for
the long time where they didn't play any
games
and then the marlins was out a couple of
kids go out and on the street and uh
you know wind up with it and and all of
a sudden now you they're being
penalized for what makeup games and
doing stuff and you don't have enough
days off
to make up all these games and now you
can't fly to philadelphia and play a
doubleheader and you can't go to st
louis and yeah the protocols were what
they are but
you know uh do you find the teams for
allowing this to happen
and you know does your does your family
all of a sudden they're the ones that
got it at home and you come home and
they give it to you you can't be for
sure that the
the team gave it to you and so i mean
it it sets so many different scenarios
and they're gonna have to do it on
percentages you cannot like you said you
cannot make up these games you cannot
get to the point and now the reds got a
couple of little
you know blips and they're all they're
all for the weekend and now you're
rearranging your
all you got to do is have a if you're
worried about your third and fourth
starters you just go ahead and say
somebody's got coped
take a couple days off and you bring the
aces back in here's one and two right
here well let's go with them
well
are you going to penalize that your your
you know the danettes for
coming in and you know and not taking
care of themselves
uh they haven't taken care of themselves
but now's not the time to start
punishing him johnny
and i'm still i'm still worried about
ritzy cheating on that test and i don't
want to bring it up again but
i mean that you know this it just wasn't
you know very smart events like telling
your wife yeah i'm thinking about having
my prayer you know
so well and i i realized that fritzy
actually
broke your heart that this emotionally
touched you that you found out that
fritzy
who you know it seems like a moral guy
his moral compass is
pointing north he's our ernie banks he's
already always ready to play too
and then he cheats off his neighbor's
paper in high school and he graduated
second in his class of 600 johnny
no no no no really yes sir i didn't hear
that
yes and i think that there keep this in
mind johnny
you know fritzy's favorite baseball team
oh the red the astros cheaters
oh no no well he was the front runner at
that bit
but i'm you know if you were doing it
it's like the heisman trophy when they
gave it back
with rachel yeah reggie did it get back
to usc then
maybe prince you should think about the
having that medal and finding out who
that person had finished third in the
class
and send it and send it to them also
i've got a solution because the reds
were talking about having
people you know fans in the stand and
they could mark off six or seven seats
and then you could sit in there
and the kansas city's talking about
having sixteen thousand
just call it a protest everybody can
come
good to talk to you as always johnny
thank you
thank you buddy thank you that's the
hall of famer are you doing good
yeah yeah we're all doing good
pretty uh pretty boring around here okay
well that's the way life is now
all right but school started back here
we got school we got the kids back in
school they're actually in person in
school and
so my life is back to routine and i'm
loving it so we're doing well down here
in florida right now
thank you bud thank you that's uh johnny
bench hall of famer